here's all the structures we've made at  cabin land together so far in order so  this is the very first thing we built  together we call it the truck cabin  um she's pretty badass next is the  diamond cabin it took us about six weeks  to build it's around 90 square feet and  we lived in it while we built our main  house now before we could build our main  house we needed water so next we made  this it is the pump house it houses our  water pumps and filtration system for  our well now because we're living in a  tiny 90 square foot cabin we needed to  make this real quick because I have a  lot of clothes so this is the Wardrobe  cabin and then we finally got to build  the main house AKA The Castle cabin it  took us about two years to build here it  is from another angle the last thing  we've built here so far is this pyramid  cabin which is currently being used as a  garden shed that's it let me know if you  want to see the insides of these